[Music]
thank you so much i didn't know he was
going to mention the sewing part but it
is very cool i still like 3d printed
buttons and things like that for my
clothes i have an instagram if you want
to check it out it's uh it's a pretty
fun way of combining like tech with
creativity stuff
anyway though i'm so excited to be here
this is actually the first talk i've
given in three years which is probably
the same for most of the speakers but so
excited that it's here in budapest
[Applause]
so i'm going to talk about the emotional
chaos of deploying code and you're
probably all wondering already like
since when does deploying code emotional
like it's one of those things that's
just so process filled that it doesn't
feel like there's really any room for
emotion like you probably have a ci cd
pipeline set up and some sort of process
or like a button you push and we just do
it all the time as developers so it
doesn't really feel like there's room
for emotion when you're doing this very
technical thing
but um i think probably the if you're
thinking of emotional chaos when it
comes to deploying code maybe the thing
that first comes to mind is when deploy
goes wrong and the servers catch fire
and you're like scrambling to get
everything back up i i was listening to
uh tejas introducing one of the speakers
this morning saying how he was at the
booth and like quickly pushed to
production closed his laptop and then
ran away so hopefully he didn't have
like any of that kind of chaos going
down when everything crashed from uh
from deploying that way but that whole
side of emotion is not actually what i'm
going to be talking about because as
developers we're probably all pretty
familiar with that i want to talk more
about the side of things that is hidden
and the things that are really important
to look at outside of the technical part
of deploying code
one of the things though that i get
asked most often when i like tell people
that i'm doing this talk is they ask if
i have like a bunch of stories of times
that i've screwed up and like chaotic
deploys that i've done
basically this whole talk is like times
that i've screwed up i've screwed up a
lot
it's not going to be anything on the
technical side but just to like satisfy
that curiosity i've done everything from
causing major outages to
running like too many tasks that like
are important like api query rate limit
is like hit within the first hour of the
day
my favorite time that i i really did
something bad was when
i was working on this like enterprise
level sas apple the type of thing where
people pay half a million dollars a year
to use this thing and for whatever
reason i deployed a bunch of chicken
heads as the icon set for it
and we didn't notice until people
started messaging and being like what's
with the chickens
so anyway that's why i'm in management
now
i swear i can still write good code
but uh yeah so i'm i'm a senior
engineering manager at fellow i'm based
in ottawa canada and i mean tjs already
gave a great intro to fellow but we are
meeting management's productivity
platform so really great at being able
to create agendas take meeting notes
track action items and really do
everything around the whole meeting
productivity suite of things um so i'm
working there i have been in the
industry for a little over 10 years now
and one of the big things i wanted to
mention too is i have actually just
written a book
thanks
so this book is called remote
engineering management and i i've been
at working remotely for the last 10
years actually so basically my entire
career uh was working remotely before it
was cool and through that like as the
talk is about all my failures i've had a
lot of failures working remotely too and
this book is basically a some summary of
everything i've learned and a really
great like people first way of managing
teams so everything from like remote
specific biases to look out for in
hiring all the way to how to give really
good and fair like feedback and
promotions so this is coming later this
summer if you want to be notified when
it's available you can sign up on my
website there
s.dev book for a notification
anyway so for the emotional chaos of
deploying code i want to start off by
talking about a deploy that has gone
wrong a deploy that has then gone right
and then how you can get from one to the
other
we're gonna do that in a story
so once upon a time there was some code
to deploy
chapter one preparing the build
so the engineering team has been working
hard on new feature in their enterprise
sas application we can print its
javascript because we're at jsconf
and we have decided that it's going to
be ready to deploy at some point later
this week
so emily the qa engineer is starting to
do a little bit more testing to make
sure that this is going out and ready to
go qa is incredible by the way they
don't get nearly enough credit
um and she's finding all these bugs and
the engineers are saying like that's not
a big deal we'll we'll fix that later
which is something that i am very guilty
of doing
there is a deploy in sight and so rami
an engineer starts to decide that he
wants to go build another feature and
sneak it into the deploy which is
something i still do today which is not
good so remy is trying to like get this
going and starts to cut
corners instead of cutting scope for
this thing to be deployed
there's also a new engineer on the team
maria
and this is the first time that
something that maria has built is going
live to production but since it's the
first time she doesn't really know
uh what's going on and hasn't done this
before it doesn't really know what this
process is going to look like
chapter two planning the deploy
there's another engineering team here
and they've broke they've built
something that's also going live but
they have broken it and it's making it
hard to test things so we have to wait
for them to be done with that there's
also a marketing team here and amir from
the marketing team uh needs to know when
this is going out so that he can plan
for the content around this to properly
promote the developer's work but it
doesn't know when that release is
actually going to happen
at some point the the day of the release
at 9 00 am everyone decides uh 3 p.m
we're going to do the deploy and
for in this case like this is a remote
or not necessarily remote but like
distributed team so there's someone who
lives eight hours ahead and uh is
planning on being asleep by then i guess
that means it's 11 p.m i normally go to
bed at like 10 30 so that seemed
reasonable for me but i know that's
that's not really the same for everyone
chapter three
deploy time
kierthi from the engineering team has
built a small part of this thing that's
going out and they're waiting around by
their computer like when the deploy is
happening not really sure
if they're supposed to be doing anything
and that's uh that's not great at 11 pm
all right the deploy takes place uh
everything goes well the code stays out
or the server stays up nothing catches
fire that's awesome and it's not over
yet deploys continue long after the code
has actually gone out so the day after
dave from the sales team has their first
prospect demo of the day and they didn't
know about the changes and it totally
messes up their demo and i've done this
to people multiple times they always
feel so bad but sales people have like a
demo that they do and they click around
things and if you change up the
navigation on them it does not go over
well
uh antonio on the support team is
getting a whole bunch of questions now
from uh clients asking about how the new
feature works but antonio did not get to
see it before and so they spend a little
longer actually writing responses and
missed some of their target metrics for
doing that
and then the whole engineering team is
just sitting around like watching like
not just sitting around but like they
are watching to see how the feature is
performing and how people are actually
starting to adopt this new thing
all right and that is the end of the
deploy
sort of
so
it look i know i pointed out in some
things like what went wrong but like
overall that's a pretty typical deploy
like code goes out no one really
communicates too much things happen
but uh it did not go over well and a lot
of people's core needs weren't being met
and there was a lot of chaos going
behind on
the chaos going on behind the scenes
that wasn't very visible and apparent up
front
so there's this
model of core needs that i really like
by paloma medina and it's called the
biceps model and this is a series of
core needs that
are that people need to feel whenever
they're working together in some sort of
organization or family or any kind of
like group setting of humans and people
need to feel like they belong and that
they have choice and they have
significance and and all these different
things and as soon as any one of these
core needs isn't being met people will
start to have a threat response and
they'll start to feel a little iffy and
and won't really feel good
one of my favorite applications of this
model is so lara hogan wrote this
article
dealing with surprising human emotions
desk moves and something as simple as
changing the seating arrangement in an
office can trigger like all of these
different threat responses because if if
you were sitting close to the ceo at
first and then your desk was moved to be
like close to the washroom you're gonna
feel like people think you're less
important because that's a pretty cool
spot going to a not so cool spot uh or
if your
back is to all the people then you don't
feel as good either so there's like this
model is kind of applicable to basically
any type of thing that happens in life
and there's this quote that i like from
an article that april wenzel wrote right
that says taking time to care about
other people's emotions isn't just kind
is actually more efficient if it leads
to smoother interactions that don't
trigger people's threat responses and i
think this is very true like the reason
that it's important to consider this
biceps model and think about how people
are feeling
depending on without them even having to
say how they're feeling it's very
important because the less people feel
threatened the more efficiently people
are going to work together and the
better everything is going to be
so how each person actually felt
emily the qa engineer her core need that
was being kind of threatened there is
significance because when an engineer
says to a qa person that like these bugs
you found aren't important we're going
to address them later
they don't feel so good because their
job is to maintain the quality of the
product and to point out these things
that are going wrong so for someone to
tell them no that whole job that you've
just done doesn't really matter it
doesn't feel
very good
for the person rami who was like
speeding up to fit uh his future into
the deploy there is some issues with
predictability there where like suddenly
um i know this is like romney itself
who's like trying to speed this up but
because nobody said no like you
shouldn't do this these are the features
going into the deploy then it's um a
little bit it feels a little bit odd for
rami because he doesn't know whether his
code's going to go out or not and that
predictability is being threatened
same thing with maria who is doing a
deploy for the very first time she's
never seen this process before doesn't
know what it looks like doesn't know if
she's gonna have to do anything for it
and so predictability is an issue there
too
amir from the marketing team this is
where it starts to get like a little bit
more complex i think the the main like
issues with
um emotions and chaos and deploys is
like how engineers communicate with
other members of the organization
because it's so easy to forget about
them when we're not communicating
day-to-day but amir from marketing team
was trying to create content and there
was no date set and it or no date was
communicated to him and so it doesn't
feel
very nice because he doesn't feel like
the engineers are thinking of him quite
as much as they should
will the engineer uh
he's the one who lives eight hours ahead
and it's going to be bedtime during the
release so i think the the core need
here that's being threatened is
belonging because i've i've been guilty
of this too very often where there are
some engineers in a different time zone
and i'll set like let's say a meeting
for nine in the morning people are three
hours behind me and that's six am
and they have to remind me like i'm not
going to be awake by then and that is
always hurtful because then they don't
feel like they're being thought of they
don't feel like they're really a part of
the team because you're not considering
them kierthi the engineer uh kind of
similar in that sense uh significance so
she wrote a small portion of the code
and isn't really sure whether she's
supposed to be sitting around for the
deploy and doing anything um that extra
bit of communication goes a long way to
make people feel like they're a part of
the team
dave from the sales team this is uh very
similar to the other people too a lot of
core needs not being met here
belonging because nobody thought to show
him the the changes going out ahead of
time and thinking about the impact it's
going to have on his work equality
predictability all of these things that
go into
a product changing
all of a sudden
antonio from the support team is very
similar to
uh the sales demo where it feels very
bad to suddenly have a bunch of support
support queries coming in when you don't
know the answers to things and nobody
thought to help you out and show you
these things ahead of time
and the engineering team predictability
this is where everyone's sitting around
like hoping to see how the features are
doing and what's going on and
predictability here is the uh the one
that you want to look out for
i find it's always nice to reassure an
engineering team when something is going
live that no matter what happens like
you did a great job the work that you
did is good
um because
yeah sometimes things go live and then
nobody uses them and that always feels
bad so you don't want people feeling
that way
and this is all relevant to teams like
no matter how you work all types of
teams are going to feel these sorts of
emotions but remote teams in particular
there's a very large impact on them and
that's specifically because when you're
working in person it's a bit easier to
tell how someone's doing and how they're
feeling because you get that body
language you can see it's a bit harder
to mask your emotions but when you're
working remotely it's so easy to just
write on slack or whatever it is saying
like yep all good i'm happy and then
behind the screen just actually feel
really bad and not feel like it's okay
to say how you're doing or say like i
don't know what's going on can you
clarify so it's especially something to
look out for on remote teams
so hopefully nobody is thinking like
this isn't happening for us
i'm pretty sure it is at least in part
because even with me like i have written
this talk and i still screw this up all
the time
so it's probably
pretty common
but what does a good deploy actually
look like then
so going through the story again once
upon a time there was some code to
deploy
the engineering team has been working on
this thing again
and emily the qa engineer is doing a
whole bunch of testing
and
emily works with the developers to plan
out what is an acceptable bug state and
work with the developers to triage
issues to maintain a backlog to fix
later so instead of engineers just
saying like nope doesn't matter we'll do
it later
you really want to work together to make
sure that you're on the same page before
any bugs are reported to figure out what
is actually
going to be acceptable or not
so ramy who is the person who is trying
to pick up the pace to get that feature
in before the deploy goes out um ramy
has been told that like these are the
features that are going out and or not
him specifically being told that but
like it has been established that this
is the series of features that are going
to go live and so he recognizes that
it's not nice to sneak a feature in last
minute that's not fair to qa or support
or sales or marketing or like anybody
else who would suddenly be surprised by
this new thing going out
uh for maria whose code is going out for
the very first time uh
not so worried with predictability
because hopefully there is a nice
thoughtfully written deploy process
somewhere in your team documentation and
that should i like i always love having
team documentation for everything in
general because it's so much easier to
just respond with a link like instead if
someone asks you how do you do this
thing instead of going over it with them
and having a call or like writing out
this long message every time just
putting that in a team doc somewhere and
sending out that link so that you might
spend like 20 minutes doing that which
is longer than spending five minutes
saying it out loud but that 20 minutes
like compounded for all the people who
are gonna ask that save so much time and
and yeah so i'd recommend doing in
general for basically everything process
related on your team
uh but anyway so she's read through the
team docs and knows exactly what is
going to happen
so for planning the deploy
the other engineering team built the
feature for the deploy and they
are a little bit more diligent in what
they put on staging for testing because
they know that
other teams are going out so the main
thing here is just like communicating a
lot between teams
amir from the marketing team is
he knows when the dates are for the
deploy because he's been in constant
communication with the team's manager
and so everything goes well he knows
when his work has to be done
uh will who lives in the time zone eight
hours ahead uh
can be asleep by 11 because everyone
remembered about will and remembered
that he lives in a different time zone
and explicitly pointed out ahead of time
it's okay you don't have to be here we
know it's late you can go to sleep
deploy time
uh kierthi
who is the person who wrote a small
feature for this deploy
everyone recognizes that she might be
wondering whether or not she's actually
needed for this and she has been told
you don't have to be here but you're
welcome to be here and so she decides to
go cheer everyone on and the deploy
happens code doesn't go down
and the day after
dave has their first sales demo of the
day and he knew all about the demo and
are all about the new changes and his
demo was so good he sells a million
seeds and makes a lot of money
antonio was able to write the
documentation for the new features ahead
of time and so kept hitting his targets
whenever any questions came in
from clients and everything went really
well
the engineering team is watching the
metrics to see how their feature gets
adopted and it doesn't really matter in
the end like it's great if it gets
adopted really well but they have
support from their manager who has told
them that um no matter what like it was
a it was a good job
all right and that is the good
deploy so
how do you actually get there
it's it's not so much like a one-step
process there's a lot of stuff involved
to actually get to a point where things
run really smoothly like that and as you
can tell like it's it's not just like
communicating with the engineering team
it's communicating with every other team
and
working on documentation and many
different things like that but i think
that the most important aspect of this
is working on emotional intelligence and
psychological safety within your teams
and what that means like it's a term
that's thrown around a lot but what that
really means to me is creating an
environment on the team where people
feel safe to fail and safe to ask
questions without thinking that people
are going to think that they're not
smart or they don't know what they're
doing and it it takes a lot of work to
get to that environment and uh it's um
it's it's a really good thing to do
because it means that people are going
to be willing to ask more questions
which means people are going to
continuously learn and learn from each
other and it just makes the team better
overall
uh some actual like bullet points of how
to how to really get there though so the
first step for all of this overall is
just over communicate as much as
possible especially in remote teams
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is assuming that people know what they
know and
so really what you want to do is if
you think that like the feature set
going out should be limited to this say
so in writing orally like in a million
different places multiple times because
people will miss like no matter how many
times you look at channel and slack and
say like this is what's happening here's
the plan people will miss it so you
really have to over communicate over and
over and over
the next big thing is setting up
processes for informing other teams of
releases and there are a bunch of
different ways you could do this
i'm a big fan of like async
communication so
setting up uh whether it's like wiki
pages where you can talk about these
things or like slack digests or or or
things like that
for a while i was doing product sync
meetings so meetings where there would
be a representative from engineering
product qa marketing sales like all of
the the different organizations or
departments that are related to
features in some way we all just get
together and and talk about it so we'd
say these are the things we want to
deploy uh does marketing need anything
from us and then marketing would talk to
design in that meeting and we'd have
someone from sales like planning out
when this thing is going to be available
and how they should sell it and so
having like
meetings where you can actually talk to
each other like that are very very
useful
i would also look out for changes in
communication patterns with your
teammates this is a good way of figuring
out whether or not someone is doing okay
and it's a little bit hard but if
someone is maybe not so talkative in
meetings as normal or not writing as
many messages as they would or like the
tone is a bit different that might be a
sign that something is a little bit off
uh related to deploys or not like maybe
it might be a sign like if they're new
to the team and uh and they're talking a
bit different maybe they're a bit
nervous and you should reach out and see
if they're doing okay but it's good to
look for that in general anyway to see
how people are doing
another big thing is to put yourself in
their shoes so that's uh that's really
important for
the the engineers but then also every
other team just figuring out like if i
was
on the marketing team and this thing
went live
how would i feel would i
be uh wanting to know more about it so
that i can create marketing material for
it uh if i'm an engineer who's new to
the team like how am i going to feel
about a deploy
happening for the first time so doing
that is a really good way of figuring
out what kind of processes you need to
make deploys go as smoothly as possible
setting clear expectations and
boundaries around code deploys is also
very good so determining ahead of time
like who is going to do what like who's
going to push the button if you have a
button or who is going to be the one to
stay up and make sure that the code is
still running setting that stuff ahead
of time removes a lot of the risk of
people feeling their sense of
predictability being hurt
and i'm always an advocate as well for
like asking ques for questions and
feedback from people so
uh especially in like 101s or
retrospectives just asking people like
how do you think that went and very like
pointed directed questions are very
likely to get some interesting insights
that you hadn't thought of which can
help make your deploys go better
so overall next steps to help make your
uh your code deploys be a little less
chaotic start by asking for feedback
from all of the different engineers and
people that you work with
try to build up that emotional
intelligence on the team psychological
safety things like that and formalizing
communication so making sure that you
have a good set of communication
processes between you and the other
teams that you work with
and
so the examples here were all around
deploying code but i mean this is
like basically everything that we do as
engineers has like this set of emotions
that aren't really visible and aren't
really talked about very often and i
would suggest
being really like on the lookout for
that and thinking about
how people feel and what you can do to
make everyone feel more comfortable
and be better off because this is just
one of the many many many very like
emotionally charged processes
that we go through
thank you
[Applause]
you